es momento de hablar de economía quien
france24 y por ello recibo con mucho
gusto a daniela blandón ramírez el
especialista económica daniela muy
bienvenida también para ti iniciamos hoy
con el desplome de los mercados
mundiales
alan muy buenas noches pues el mercado
tiene los nervios de punta hoy en día
hubo un nuevo récord diario de casos
globales en kobe de 19 que sobrepasaron
el medio millón
por eso wall street se hundió más del 35
por ciento en su peor resultado desde
junio el petróleo se desplomó casi un 6%
en ambas referencias pero si nos vamos a
europa francia volvió a decretar
confinamiento y alemania impuso un
bloqueo parcial de un mes sus bolsas
perdieron entre el 3 y el 4 por ciento y
en américa latina' no se quedaron atrás
los mercados
buenos aires- acumula casi un 18% de
caída en apenas tres días hablan
vámonos con noticias del gobierno cubano
y de una firma de transferencias de
dinero que evalúan opciones para seguir
recibiendo remesas la historia a la
siguiente estados unidos prohibió
recientemente a los negocios de
cualquier estadounidense con fin simex
que es una empresa manejada por los
militares cubanos porque dice que usa
sus ganancias para reprimir a sus
ciudadanos sin simex a su vez es el
socio principal de western júnior que
tramita las remesas en la isla el
gobierno cubano asegura que si no se
encuentra una agencia alternativa para
manejar estas transacciones tendrá que
cerrar 407 oficinas de western y unión
el próximo 27 de noviembre expertos
dicen que anualmente les llegan unos
3500 millones de dólares a los
residentes de la isla que dependen del
dinero que sus familiares envían desde
el exterior
daniela y que pasó en la bmc se enredó
la elección de la nueva directora de la
organización mundial del comercio pues
si alan en este momento hay dos mujeres
en carrera por el cargo una vez la
ministra surcoreana de comercio
y la otra es la ex ministra de finanzas
de nigeria and go sí
okonjo iweala después de consultar con
los 164 países miembros se llegó a la
conclusión de que la candidata africana
es la que reúne la mayoría de apoyos
pero necesitaban un consenso y hubo sólo
un país que decidió romperlo adivine
cuáles aquí le contamos
con eeuu dijo que apoyaba a la ministra
y debido a sus 25 años de experiencia
comercial que podría funcionar muy bien
dijeron que no podían respaldar a la
doctora gos y no sé sus razones tendría
que preguntarles a ellos se celebrara
una reunión del consejo general el 9 de
noviembre en la que esperamos tomar una
decisión sobre este asunto tan
importante
recordemos que donde bueno eso para nada
amigo de la organización mundial del
comercio
otra organización con la que ha tenido
conflictos buenos escocia están haciendo
ahí combustibles con lo que es obra de
la fabricación del whisky bueno dicen
que uno no debe mezclar el alcohol y los
autos pero esta excepción ocurre en el
país que más produce whisky en el mundo
que es escocia allí una empresa fabrica
combustible para autos a base de
desechos de fabricación de whisky a los
fabricantes les sale más barato
regalarle a esta empresa los granos de
cebada y la levadura que sobran que
pagar altas sumas para deshacerse de
ellos de manera segura
los presidentes de silicon valley
acudieron al capitolio de los estados
unidos- daniela hablando precisamente de
estas noticias empresariales que
involucran al gobierno del presidente de
eeuu donald trump estuvieron allí una
vez más pero ya no por su poder
dominante como siempre sino para
responder por su papel en los contenidos
que se mueven por internet en especial
en esta época de elecciones y de
coronavirus el congreso busca reformar
la ley de internet que hoy protege a las
empresas de la responsabilidad por lo
que publiquen sus usuarios los citados
fueron los presidentes de google
facebook y twitter este último tuvo un
cruce de palabras muy interesante con el
senador t culos
el señor doors y quién diablos lo eligió
y lo puso a cargo de lo que los medios
pueden informar lo que el pueblo
estadounidense puede escuchar y por qué
persiste en comportarse como un super
pac demócrata para silenciar las
opiniones contrarias a sus creencias
políticas y no estamos haciendo eso y es
por eso que abrir esta audiencia
pidiendo más transparencia nos damos
cuenta de que necesitamos ganar más
confianza así que escuchó las preocupa
y las reconozco pero queremos
solucionarlo con más transparencia por
transformers muchas gracias por este
recorrido económico daniela blandón
ramírez la especialista y gracias a
ustedes por su compañía vea más en
francés 24
[Música]